this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you Kelly for a long introduction
and thank you shipping for hosting me
today
thank you all for being here
today I will talk about last four to
five years of my research in blueberry
not mine our our research in blueberries
blueberries are one of the fewer crops
that have been domesticated in North
America they are perennial shrubs
the current economic value of
blueberries is around 1 billion dollars
blueberries have
high amount of compound phytosampounds
like anthocyanins phenolic acids and
flavonides and so on so Health
benefiting compounds along with vitamins
and many Trace elements
um many research studies shows that
regular consumption of flu varies
helps
reducing the wear and tear of
age-related issues
because of this increased awareness of
blueberries there is a increasing demand
demand also is increasing for last two
decades so you can see here
there is a continuous demand of our
blueberries conjunction the green line
is the conjunction has been increasing
from 2100 Watts even though production
also has been increased to meet the
demand we can still we are still
importing a large portion of blueberries
from other countries
so that leaves us
scope or further expansion of
blueberries also crop Improvement
I just wanted to give you a brief
introduction here about until I just
wanted to show you a brief introduction
of different blueberry species
yeah
blueberries fall under the family
advocacy and the next hierarchy in this
one is the genus vaccinium under this
genus there are more than 200 to 400
species are there but typically what we
call them as blueberries are from the
section sign of caucus it may be around
200 species
there are few terminology I don't want
to take up too much time but it's
important to give you some introduction
uh the cultivated blueberries are called
High Bush blueberries basically we are
the large they are larger plants easy to
cultivate and um for Horticulture
maintenance is easier and and bigger
fruits so and so
you see in the Frozen sections in the
grocery stores and also what blueberries
that you see in the processing food are
all from the lowest blueberry
what you see on the fresh market the
fresh blueberries that we get those are
high boost blueberries
I wish blueberries are typically grown
in Canada and Northern parts of the
United States
so many other cultivated blueberries or
tetraploids however uh cultivated
foreign
however we also have diploids and it
supports the logo there is mostly our
set of points
all a southern species
and 10 LM they are mostly low Bush and
grown in southern subtropical regions of
the United States
we are considering because I'm talking
about the higher high temperature stress
tolerance so they may have some genes
that can contribute to the high
temperature tolerance also
like
originally uh blueberries were grown in
northeastern parts of the U.S and Canada
but however now we are growing them
um in canals and Florida and so and so
places uh and also in South America
because we have developed Southern
types also so Southern High Bush types
we developed by introdressing the
Northern High bush with Southern species
the blueberries I was talking to I think
shipping the morning how the blueberries
are acid loving plants however you can
grow so there are very finicky plants to
grow and the best ideal temperature is
in between four and five soil based
temperatures there are also shallow root
system so
since they have shallow root system and
also likes moist soil you have to have a
well moist soil but good drainage also
so if you have a stagnant water they
cannot survive so there's a few tips to
grow blueberries
and they also have a long juvenile
period compared to many other plants so
you can able to see fruits and flowers
after two to three years of cuttings and
other if it is coming from the seeds
minimum three years but you can see a
good fruit yield once they attain eight
to ten years of age
so why what is the need for uh
Improvement for blueberries we already
growing everywhere and what is the need
but since the blueberries are
relatively new crop I say that because
we domesticated only a century ago
around 1920s and that time so from that
time only we started applying our
selection process
um
so there is a there is a scope for a lot
of improvement and also last 20 years we
can see expansion of crop geographically
as well as the consumption
of course if we think about any proper
Improvement we first think about high
areas right so we want the farmers to be
profitable and then fruit Improvement a
fruit quality so fruit quality is here
we talks in a different languages here
so when we talk about Fresh Market we
wanted to have sweeter food
um the good appealing one also we should
be able to Mechanical um
um handle a very well for transportation
so and so qualities but if you are
talking about
um Ocean Spray or other juice making
companies they would like to have
um more acidic and within the acid
balance uh juice because we don't want
to have ad we don't want to add so many
additives now in our juice products or
any products so they would like to see a
different ratios of acid profile in the
fruit
and as a consumer for Fresh Market we
wanted to have sweet fruits and
appealing one and they may say and in
addition to that major
input cost for growing blueberries is
harvesting right so for Fresh Market we
still in majority of the cases we are
harvesting by hand that is the highly
um one of the costiest input that we are
investing
the so far what we selected blueberries
are for looking at the yield
taste so and so quality is not meant for
um using machines to harvest so there is
the room for improving plant heart
architecture that can allow easy
easy harvesting with machines which can
include
the employers now if you have a closed
compact inflorescence
it will not be possible you may you may
lose a lot of green foods and also if
the whole influor is inserted by
ripening at different stages also you
will not be getting as much yield as
possible so we would like to see some
open inflorescence where uh and also the
all the floors can measure at least
majority of the fruits can mature or
ripen at the similar time so that would
be an ideal architecture of the
blueberries for mechanical harvesting
and when you have intense cropping for
any crops it'll have pests and diseases
so naturally we have a room for
improvement over there and my interest
last four or five years is look at the
high temperature stress tolerance and
there have been a lot of studies done
for freeze tolerance I know these are
two contrasting uh things but there is
another another date of thought for
pre-tolerance but for today I'll focus
on high temperature stress
okay
so remember one thing is that um
there are nothing High buries are
um
originated and then uh in the temperate
regions but now we are cultivating in
Beyond with their natural habitat so
California are many places almost 40
States in U.S as well many states and
here uh just to prove not true that in
addition to that we can see
in this graph
the number of heat waves okay
for a year was over in an average two
heat Waves per year in six days but now
it's almost six uh average six heat
Waves per year that we have been looking
at
and also the link there's a heat wave
season is it was almost 20 days per year
it used to be but in the 60s and now it
is almost 70 days more than two months
this two months coincides with where the
fruit um
flowering and fruit development is
happening it's very crucial but not then
I Bush blueberries to have some innate
resistance to the high temperatures
tolerance
so here I say uh what happens when also
we see even in this season what we saw
in the places where we never had like 45
degrees temperature in
northern Europe and many places here as
well so what happens when you have 35
and above degree for a couple of days or
three days
um
the the fruits wherever the sun exposure
happens will become softened and then
shrivel and then when as other info the
physiological maturity happens they
become like um dry fruits
because of necrosis the typical symptom
that you see and the leaves are
scorching
so this also has been published in one
of the papers not from our lab but you
know it's a background information for
this study
we were looking at whether when we
thought about high temperatures because
not much research has been done in this
um
high temperature stress area for
blueberries so we were looking whether
um the existing varieties
exhibit any variation for this trade so
in this study they
um this uh they had they tested
and four different varieties and also
look at the electrolyte leak case and
the temp and MDA accumulation so here
you can see the susceptible variety
brigata
uh has a higher amount of electrolyte
leakage when temperatures hit 40 degrees
the same way higher levels of MDA in
every guitar susceptible one with a
higher MDA levels at 40 degrees but
until 30 degrees Centigrade you don't
see a big difference
the significant difference same way here
for other photosynthesis and
fluorescence parameters you can see the
difference among the genotypes when the
temperatures reaches 40 degrees
43 degrees in France for three days or
four days so those are the times
um were critical for blueberry and also
it coincides with the fluid development
so this is the seedling or seedling
tolerance so short blue has a fewer
plants will last but in the Brigade
almost 43 percent of the plants was Gone
with high temperature stress
so with this background we thought maybe
we can look for candid genes
um
from the genotypes that we have are we
can make new classes and then see
all else are genes that can help with
the hair temperature crystalline
so we decided we will go with um
deployed species so that way it's easier
for us to do the genomic analysis and
also when we started we didn't have
um a reference genome for blueberries so
we start with the best strategy to use a
deployed you know deployed species so
foreign version is one of the parents
and the doorway is one of the parents in
our process
from Southern collected in Florida
um
Southern States and Karim bosom is from
New Jersey area
from the spacious and you can also see
the difference in the leaf mod quality
the current version is a deciduous
plants it sheds leaves in the winter
time
protein and the leaf orientation is
different that can help withstand with
high temperatures so in the back side
you can hear me right
yes
so one of my graduate student previously
grad student and she looked at it is
there any uh diff um physiological
anatomical differences are there between
these two parents before we initiate a
studies so
she imposed of 40 degrees like um
mimicking the daytime temperature until
40 degrees and then collected Leaf
samples as I said zero six hours and
nine hours and then looked at the
scanning my electron microscopy so what
you see and the red dots why he is a
chlorophyll structure of the chlorophyll
and the gray color is the stomata
foreign
structure so at 40 degrees 0 hours 6
hours and 9 hours so we can assume or I
can see that the chlorophyll is almost
intact the intact how I can say that you
can see high intensity red structures
here whereas in a car in bosom you can
see small small tiny dots everywhere so
what happened there at least our theory
is what happened the chloroplast may
have the bus stop and and the thylakides
and stoma they just popped up so what
how I explain that is that chlorophyll
is packed tightly like a small purse
with stacks of coins and you have a high
pressure with the high temperature
because of the cellular damage it's
happening so the thylakites Mischief is
still open like you have the coins spill
open so you don't have the type anymore
so that's how you have smaller dots of
tiny dots as you can see in the scanning
error term it was working and the
current version whereas in that away
from a southern species you can see it
will almost intact chloroplast
in and I also we looked at the stomata
Astro metal opening uh in the clock in
the current version you can see there's
almost a similar opening uh as we
progress with the temperature but here
in Darwin as
we go out by nine or nine hours or six
hours we can start the string closing
are slightly closing up the stomata is
the indicator of
um tolerance to the high temperatures
stress
I think these are a good candidates for
uh studying for them and we took a Divas
and gene expression studies to find
genes
So within five years I it's impossible
for me to establish a Crossings and uh
study so I collaborated with Dr Nick
Wilson from Rutgers
um she's retired now but he was gracious
enough to share his research experiments
and shared his germ plasm and the
population with me for my studies
so what we be what you see here the
parents OTB different clones 15 and 88
are different floors of 4pb is current
body and then different clones are for
that away so we made two sets of process
since the also I wanted to warn you here
that uh these parents are not homozygous
like what you see having um rice and
other
um soya bean so you have a homozygous
parents but these are already very high
heterozygous so
um we'll start with it and then if once
we cannot self them because they have a
highly Prosper they are highly crossed
polluted species uh highly selfish
um self incompatibility is there so you
have to cast them to get a feed so we
developed a pseudo have to population we
had around almost 1000
um F2 so do I have to population but we
plants
so here are the F2 that we
um
itself you can see individually it's not
the shade so there are some plants um
with good tolerance and there are we can
see this party symptom coming between
layers and here is the one uh with Dr
outside his group with us with him we do
fruit acids and phenotyping would have
put acids and sugars
phenotyping uh we took both sides one
way what are the the first responses
will happen in the plant the plant
damage when exposed to the temperature
the other way and other side we also
measure few things
um few parameters that inherently what
defense mechanisms plants can exhibit so
as a biomarkers
oh
yeah
he's from our lab and he's measuring
this is chlorophyll and the fluorescent
parameters with poly pin manotyping
foreign
tolerant plants that you see on the top
row uh you don't see any scorching
however
um the bottom row you can see the
scorching effect
sorry these are the sensitive plants and
the top floor can be a resistant to
plants they have to
yeah
and then once we have collected data we
looked the frequency distribution how
they look in the population so you can
see normal distribution for majority of
the parameters that include and for the
quantum yields we can we have the
sequence distribution also looked at the
box plots to take the range of range for
uh for this population so it's a pretty
decent for uh to go with the G bus
parameters
we also looked at the heritability
because this is our first time we are
working with this crop and this uh
parameters whether they are heritable
they will be connected for any of the
streets since we have a decent
heritability so we still hope for now we
can have a hope for better Improvement
on these trades
with similar
um
protocol we also have a paper published
for a different uh project
so from this uh
sequencing for this population up to 60.
we had around a billion reefs Rarities
and then
map those read bits with Draper texts
and Draper tetraploid genome so we were
able to get the reference genome by that
time we had 85 percent almost 85 percent
of mapping
and after filtration you have uh 126
000 Snips identified from this uh
frequency
when we look the Manhattan plots for
each of the trades that
has seen there are around
1323 seats that are associated with this
traits that we measured
and from here what we did we selected
um Snips that have more than that are
associated more than one trade to go
forward to make it easier
so with that we have around uh 245 Snips
that have been associated with more than
one trade and that we measured and out
of this
172 of them in the genic regions of the
organic regions of the genome
um
almost 40 genes are in the chromosome
one and
11 and 12 also have a considerable genes
from the that are associated with
multiple trades traits and multiple
parameters but they
um
heat tolerance
so these are some of the candidate genes
from those what we selected from the
G was
at the same time simultaneously I had we
had another student
uh grad student who was working on a
gene expression studies
so we use the same parents from
karimbojum and uh adaraway for gene
expression studies so she treated plants
with 45 degrees at 9 hours 6 hours and
nine hours collected samples so we do it
we took this name she also did
preliminary
experiment with
cultivars that the cultivars that we
have using uh not the nibus southern
high Bush and rabbitai different
genotypes So based on the preliminary
study we chose this time points for this
project
analysis
because these are typical sequencing
protocol that she followed
and after
um
[Music]
assembly and filtration with the quality
chests we have around 99
000 assembled genes in a karimboism
100 and
9 000 genes in that away
to move forward
so
so these are when the Venn diagram of
the down regulate upregulated genes and
then down regulated genes then we also
looked at the common genes along um
across these genotypes and across the
treatments so what we were interested uh
to go to the to pick a candid genes
about the common genes and we took this
325 common genes and cross compared with
the jivas genes is there any
um if typically they are responding we
should be able to see here also right
from what we found from jeevas that are
associated so we have around 30 genes
that are common uh in both the studies
so that is a good sign so this can be a
strong candidates candid genes for
either marker development or
um
for further studies as well
from this group studies we were able to
identify 245 candid genes
and also some both susceptible and
tolerant F2 plants so since these are
deployed we can transfer the trades that
we identified from here using classes
with the tetraploid blueberries so that
project is underway now
um
we're also developing PCR Market because
every time you cannot use the Snips
markers to at least with the facility
that we have so we are converting them
into PCR market and making them into
robust
um everyday usable matters to help aid
in the selection process
so that's the one another project also I
wanted to share quickly because it just
published yesterday and it's not for
promotion or anything but I just wanted
to share it thank you
I was talking about the second my second
and third slide there are 200 species of
blueberries so we wanted to see
we are
the reason also there is a another study
from I don't remember there is a Florida
group or Carolina school
um
even though we have several varieties of
blueberries are releasing now so for uh
to Southern to grow them in the South or
you know even or in the tropical
temperate region but most of them the
base kinetic material is coming from the
only fewer fewer plants fewer beans like
most of the Southern species have common
like Florida four are fewer few other
plants are molecular cultivars so
exploring more uh wild species there are
plenty of mild species and we we have
availability in different uh from
different groups also exploring them
characterizing them will be beneficial
for for their reading Improvement
programs so with that goal we looked one
of my Master's students projects this is
now who is who is doing PhD in Florida
he
look uh the developer identify the Snips
with the genotyping by sequencing method
and then compared the genetic relations
and I am showing I'm really interested
in this project which we found really
good stuff so just to give you a brief
idea here
um one of the Boreal
vaccinium Boreal collected in Canada
Rocky Mountains
um
Alpine region habitat and the Korean
bosom is collected from New Jersey where
you have a strong swampy areas and most
people under that area around rivers and
plates and then 10 LM is from Virginia
and North Carolina Regions and Darwin
Darwin and mercenities they were
collected in Florida and Alabama regions
some time ago
so I started using those genotypes
because they were just growing them and
I wanted to explore more with the CPC
which they can be beneficial
but in total we have we utilize uh sorry
we use 195 accessions from each species
so I think somewhere you have those
numbers also
so from those after the quality control
and everything you have 60 000 Snips
that can be utilized for uh further
analysis so when we do the PCA you have
a clear cut a separation of Southern
types all these are southern types and
these two are not the type uh
blueberries but within the northern type
Boreal is here is separated out from
foreign version but whereas the southern
types all of them at least
in in
um they didn't separate as distinctly as
the northern type
we have my time
okay so this is uh njtree this is based
on the distance
same way of Separation that you can see
in the previous slide with the PCA
um again we what we think so far is
these two uh accessions what you have
here from Boreal and foreign so there
can be a bridge action sense so that's
uh we haven't
um rooted yet but the those can serve as
a bridge actions between these two
species
and this is to talk about
um nucleotide diversity so
we have plenty more uh number of
accessions in that away even with that
we but there is a
less nucleotide diversity uh in uh daru
way compared to the 10lm and Boreal
so when you look at the admixture
um admission the first one to deviate
from all the rest of the group or
whatever we are studying is the
you have a northern type and then
Southern type and then you further
divide the Boreal got separated out
immediately and are they all the sudden
steps stayed as it is and then after
when you make four clusters then you
have 10 LM separated out
and then
after you make five or six we don't we
couldn't see the separation between a
messianitis and that away so we we're
thinking they are admixtures because of
their habitat because they grow and the
similar conditions there may be cross
pollination happen out Crossing between
two species and it's hard to fire
um separate out
and this is also very interesting uh in
the Manhattan plots when you see the
Manhattan plots comparing with uh uh
here I'm particularly interested here
with Boreal comparing with honor there
are species you have a negative
selection here
um where you have a positive selection
here with pairways comparisons
that what you see in this craft so
um
the admission is high so you also can
see FSE is the low between those
transitions
so we also looked at the migration
events between the
species that we study uh Boreal because
it stood out immediately and then as a
big event happened uh the foreign
from the originated from the Orient and
then you have smaller events from
current version that to other species so
it it may tell us that Boreal may be the
progenator for Northern type blueberries
or blue blueberries that we call them
and we also looked at the look for the
selected sweeps are there any selective
speeds some sweeps among the species so
in chromosome 12.
we can see a selective sweep
because we choose a Korean bosom as a
comparison because that is the
cultivated one the rest of them are a
wild species so you can see it clear
selector sweep here
um probably whatever genes are there in
the chromosome 12 in this Asian are
making the natural selection or
artificial selection over other species
so that sweep region is around uh
715 based killer based space
32 genes uh that may be interesting to
look for further deep further uh uh in
deeply
some of the genes that I found among 32
were from medicine maintenance DNA
replaced processes genes so there may be
for interest for further studies and
also
difficult to summarize what we have
the other way and meditative that's why
because Boreal Memorial is in the
Canada with Rocky Mountains and so and
so are all higher altitude of habitat
the aquarium bosom is in swamp areas in
New Jersey so there may be a
there is a
not much possibility for
cross-contamination
cross pollination out Crossing between
these species but sometimes you have a
um
uh originated from the burial but
whereas in the Darwin and Miss tonight
is because they're cohabited between the
similar places so there may be a lot of
Adventure happen in those species so
that's uh our prediction from the study
and my collaborators uh networks I have
been talking about and he provided
the material and the knowledge About
Blueberries because I am very naive when
I started this project and he helped me
understand about blueberries and sharing
the knowledge and wisdom and that is the
Umesh Reddy from West Virginia state and
he was he's our my
bioinformatics you do so if I need any
analysis so he's the one I go with him
and he helps with me a lot and some of
the students are not there any now the
paper that published is from Byron he's
in Florida now and uh
all of them are Master students
graduated and everybody is being good
she's also a model now I mean
Arwen is here and Tommy joined later we
took the picture so I had to have her
separately
and this is my lab website
um people are any of you are interested
what they explore and we can stop here
and then and I'm open for questions
um in the beginning of your talk you
showed us some photographs of it through
uh in response to heat stress but I
noticed that most of your phenotyping of
heat stress was on leave for property
yes so I'm wondering how have you found
there's a good association between the
effects on leaves and the effects on
things like roots and fat
of our stats and yields I haven't
started yet that's the future study
yeah no we haven't started that so we
started with because
um for me it's easier
since we have F2 they bear flower
different times according those
experiment will become broader so
initiate with the leaves that is easier
you can measure all at one time one
extra one time exposure of the
treatments
in the future
stress um experiment you did um what was
the humidity like it was very dry or
very beautiful
I don't remember but uh
it's just in the growth from that very
important temperature so we can regulate
this mercenary is possibly an aloe
polypoid and if so does it perhaps have
the genome or poor embossum as part of
it and that would explain the ab mixture
that you see to the database yeah
hello qualified I'm not sure
that the angles so only we thought maybe
because
medicineitis has a tetrophloid version
also tetropriate so because of the
outcrossing nature there may be
admixture happen so Darwin also has the
tetropriate versions
[Music]
all of them but many of the blueberry
projects that we have the base the
genetic material is the same coming from
similar or fewer sources
um so maybe if we shine light on
different species we can use them
DIY
engine does it also have this small
leaves
the the shape is same but the little bit
bigger than yeah
but the diploids are kind plants
that's fine
yeah that's why you mentioned that one
chin has been more in
Mercedes maintenance
specifically or to assume
this is uh from The annotation where we
have to find out
that we experimentally proved we looked
at the sequences with annotations
uh
um
yeah so this one and the second one is
like a very interesting
my question is what's the role of low PH
or a woman AFV plus
how I mean this contribute to uh
or maintenance growth of February or
promote the secondary data provides of
learning proposition
I haven't used that aluminum point of
effect of aluminum point of view but I
had some bad experience when we have
soil so when we when I started this
project we just used the greenhouse
water whatever water is available on the
greenhouse
plants are terrible they look terrible
and they are not growing up and then
because when you say the start your
faculty position you haven't rushed it
you wanted to and I have undergrad
students working with me and then I
spent more time how but then we went to
the test the soil page what the the
water in the greenhouse it was like five
something
5.2 or 5.1 right plants are not
so then it literally took a
um
HCL diluted and they will be mixed with
water and then plant
um then apply it to the blueberry pots
after that two three weeks you can see
they are coming back again
pH yeah so that I can tell with
confidence but with aluminum I we
haven't tried any experimentalists
definitely that we can talk uh
I can send samples then we can answer
yeah sure if you remember so that we did
one quick question with the different
periods even if it is yes more than six
it is the plants are showing now
necrotic symptoms even if it is lesser
than three they are shown even even they
allow acidic but not lower than
yeah I think one is
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu